fr enti vendredi Dominique Bernard un
professeur de lettre a été égorgé au
sein du lycée Gambetta carnaau à haras
vous rendez compte un peu vous rendez
compte de ça rendez compte il part le
matin part le matin il va il va donner
des cours ça sa famille a dû le voir
partir et le soir il revient pas non
mais les gars mais on mais on est on est
où là s rigoler on est où on est où
excusez-moi ce drame arrivant quelques
jours avant les 3 ans plus de la mort de
Samuel pati que s'est-il passé ce drame
aurait-il pe être évité euh le profil de
l'auteur présumé desfits on en a parlé
la sécurité dans les écoles on va bien
sûr en parler et il y a Antoine ancien
élève qui veut rendre hommage à son
professeur tué vendredi euh
regardez cet homme en haut à droite
vient de s'introduire au lycée Gambetta
d'aras il est 11h passé ce matin il est
menaçant et semble armé un membre du
personnel éducatif tente de le dissuader
de rentrer dans l'établissement 1600
élèves sont scolarisés dans le lycée
g il y a une ch ils ont des couteaux il
a un couteau les gars il a un couteau a
le proviseur adjoint de leur salle de
classe ses élèves filme le courage
d'adulte qui tente de s'interposer voici
le premier qui essaie de repousser
l'assaillant à l'aide d'une chaise il
tombe alors à terre un second ramasse
alors la chaise et tombe lui aussi avant
que l'assaillant ne le frappe à
plusieurs reprises nous avons décidé de
ne pas vous montrer la suite de cette
scène ce soir on pense à tous les
professeurs qui revoit cette scène
encore tous les instituturs tous les
professeurs tout le corps enseignant qui
doit se dire parce qu'ils se
reconnaissent dans Dominique Bernard qui
est un héros aujourd'hui parce que s'il
avait pas si c'était pas interposé ça
aurait été beaucoup plus dramatique et
ça aurait été un carnage c'est un héros
aujourd'hui Antoine je voudrais te
remercier d'être avec nous aujourd'hui
tu as tu as quel âge Antoine j'ai 27 ans
27 ans tu es un ancien élève de
Dominique Bernard oui je suis très
content que tu sois là ce soir parce que
Dominique Bernard est un un héros
c'était ton professeur combien d'années
tu l'as eu en je l'ai eu 3 ans durant le
collège donc les TR les trois dernières
années du collège donc 5e 4e et 3e ouais
donc il y a maintenant quasi 15 ans
c'est ça voilà de 2007 à 2011 à peu près
voà et et je tu as vraiment quand on t'a
demandé de venir tu as dit oui tout de
suite pourquoi CIT un professeur que que
tu aimais beaucoup bah c'està-dire que
si je devais ressortir un professeur de
ma scolarité c'est lui je pense je pense
qu'on a tous un ou plusieurs professeurs
qui nous restent en tête même quand on a
60 70 ans et bah je je pense que
j'aurais sorti son nom si on m'avait
demandé voilà pourquoi parce qu'il était
déjà passionné ça c'est sûr euh gentil
avec les
élèves et il avait une qualité qu'on
demande pas forcément dans un premier
temps à un professeur mais en plus de ça
il était drôle ouais donc en fait ce
qu'il avait du mal à faire passer il le
faisait passer par l'humour ça soit en
cours ou ou à
l'extérieur toujours une petite blague
quand on le croisait en dehors du lycée
ou dans les couloirs donc voilà c'est ce
qui m'a marqué aujourd'hui il a sauvé
des
vies Dominique Bernard ça lui a coûté sa
vie d'ailleurs euh quand vous avez
appris sa mort je pense que vous étiez
dévasté bah quand déjà j'ai lu
professeur de lettres abattu au collège
Gambetta et la première chose à laquelle
j'ai enfin j'ai pensé c'est Monsieur
Bernard parce que je me suis dit que
s'il y avait bien un prof qui enin qui
aurit vous raisonna l'assaillant c'est
vrai c'était lui ah ouais donc je me
suis dit c'est Monsieur Bernard et une
heure après je lis les articles et je
vois Monsieur Bernard a battu il
essayait toujours de trouver des des
solutions de de de toujours c'était bah
un accompagnateur vraiment et exactement
comme je dis en cours comme comme en
dehors de toute façon toujours une
petite blague je toujours le sair voilà
vous avez ressenti quoi quand vous avez
appris que c'était lui bah bouleversé
clairement boulever mercé je pense qu'il
y a pas d'autres mots bien sûr voilà il
y a pas d'autres mot c'est c'est c'est
c'est fou parce que quand quand vous
nous racontez tout ça alors bien sûr
quoi qu'il arrive c'est c'est c'est
dramatique et là on on quand on connaît
encore plus le le personnage qui s'est
trouvé à à sauveré des des vies à cause
de de de de ce terroriste on se dit
c'est c'est on est on on est encore plus
triste ce soir de de de dans votre
témoignage
euh c'est c'est Gilles c'est c'est c'est
fou qu'est-ce qui s'est passé exactement
ben vous avez raison parce que s'il ne
s'interpose pas il y a eu il y a eu en
plus de lui il y a eu les agents de
sécurité un autre professeur blessé mais
s'il ne s'interpose pas au début
peut-être que les élèves n'ont pas le
temps de se confiner et en fait ça
rejoint ce que ce que Antoine nous dit
c'est-à-dire que tout de suite il s'est
dit peut-être que je vais au sacrifice
mais je vais protéger les élèves il leur
a dit courez allez vous confiner allez
vous protégé parce que la configuration
de l'établissement fait que l'agresseur
aurait pu être face à des élèves donc
c'est vraiment un héros qui qui a sauvé
des vies par sa bravoure extrême donc il
avait 57 ans il était professeur de
lettre il était père de trois filles
ouais il su d'une famille d'enseignants
et était marié à une professeur
d'anglais euh vous avez dit que c'est le
professeur qui vous AAZ le plus marqué
dans votre scolarité
euh quel est le le le le voilà le le
fait qui vous a le plus marqué quand
vous étiez avec j'ai pas forcément
d'anecdote si j'ai un souvenir c'est
vraiment toujours son sourire la bonne
humeur bon parfois on n pas forcément
envie d'aller en cours et cetera mais
euh par exemple si c'était un peu le
bazar dans les couloirs euh avec un
autre prof peut-être que ça aurait
continué Monsieur Bernard il sortait de
sa classe ouais et ça se calmait j'ai
d'ailleurs vu une enfin un témoignage
d'une d'une professeur du même lycée ou
sur les réseaux sociaux qui disait qui
enfin qui a raconté cette anecdote et
c'était exactement ça quand les élèves
le voyaient ont changé presque de
comportement par rapport à un prof euh
un peu plus banal on va dire entre
guillemets il était vraiment pas banal
en fait CIT monsieur tout le monde il a
un nom assez banal mais c'était pas
monsieur tout le monde c'est ça voilà
mais déjà je pense que c'est lui qui a
été à la rencontre de de de de ce
terroriste et c'est vrai que c'est fou
ce que vous nous avez dit y a un instant
vous nous avez dit s'il y a une personne
dans le lycée qui allait aller à la
rencontre de C de cet assaillant pour le
raisonner c'était lui exactement c'est
ça donc je quand j'ai lu les titres je
me suis dit ça ne peut être que lui prof
de en plus bien sûr donc bah ça n'a pas
raté quand euh quel quel été le
sentiment parce que nous nous voilà je
vous dis on est on était tous en colère
Antoine forcément il y a de la tristesse
énorme mais après on a une colère
immense je pense que Géraldine est
d'accord avec moi g on on est tous he on
est tous on se dit mais comment ça peut
arriver à une personne qui est sans
problème qui est là pour au contraire
former des élèves pour apprendre pour
pour donner son savoir pour apprendre
qui fait un métier exceptionnel qui est
un professeur exceptionnel tout le monde
le disait hein voilà Antoine nous le
confirme encore ce soir et il se
retrouve euh au milieu voilà d'un d'un
d'un truc qui qui ne qui qui qui ne le
concerne pas et aujourd'hui on lu a ôté
sa vie on a ôté sa vie et on a ôté on a
on a on a bousillé une famille on a
bousillé je suis sûr que les élèves
aujourd'hui c'est très compliqué de
retourner à l'école et surtout que c'est
comme il l'a dit Antoine aujourd'hui
aussi on a eu plein de témoignages
d'élèves qui disent que c'est un
professeur exceptionnel et que quand on
allait suivre ses cours c'était c'était
un honneur je sais que voilà c'est ce
que tu nous confies et 15 ans après les
tous les témoignages que j'ai lu c'est
exactement toutes les petites anecdotes
c'est exactement ce que moi j'ai vécu
c'est ça donc voilà j'ai même j'ai même
plusieurs amis que je n'ai pas forcément
vu depuis le collège quand on a appris
la nouvelle il m'ont envoyé un message
on s'était peut-être pas parlé depuis 10
ans ouais tu as vu c'est Monsieur
Bernard comme si on avait pas arrêté de
se parler en fait
donc vous avez été triste en colère vous
avez été comment bah c'est enfin quand
quand quand une personne aussi belle
entre guillemets décède sous les coups
d'un d'un malade ouais c'est quand même
difficile de passé des à la haine on va
dire ais c'est ça exactement moi je me
mets surt à la place des familles enfin
trois filles c'est c'est ça moi je pense
à sa famille aujourd'hui onz compte les
trois filles qu'on compte ça sa femme
Gilles ça c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est
il part le matin comment tu peux te
c'est une famille brisée bien sûr bien
sûr lui lui il part pour aller en cours
et puis il y a ce ce Mohamed mogutchov
mogoukov on va donner son nom qui qui le
tue son nom qui le tue voilà alors sans
doute en plus c'était prémédité il
voulait tuer un prof voilà tuer le
symbole du professeur c'est ça qui est
pouro sair alors pour le moment et ben
pour le moment il ne parle pas beaucoup
en garde à vue encore jusqu'à demain
matin demain midi en garde à vue il ne
dit pas ses motivations on ne sait pas
il provoque un peu sur les fait il ne
revient pas beaucoup donc on ne sait pas
pourquoiavais dit ici moi j'avais dit
ici que Samuel paatti fallait en faire
un héros je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez j'avais dit qu' fallait tout de
suiteoui al 3 ans j'avais dit faut faire
tout de suite une école Samuel Patti é
la famille des victimes elle en a marre
d'avoir des héros V parce que c'est
facile après d'aller sur les chaînes
infos et dire vous nous savez on
baissera pas les bras on regardera dans
les yeux on n pas peur de vous ok mais
en attendant vous avez fait quoi pour ça
paatti un rond-point une rue une école
que dalle rien il est mort pour rien et
là on recommence encore on a un autre
professeur qui qui se fait encore
égorger dans son collège dans son lycée
on a les images vous voulez en faire
quoi de ce mec qui tape des mecs au sol
ils essayent de se défendre il sort d'où
ce mec il sort de nulle part on en fait
quoi moi je veux pas faire de justice on
va pas se substituer à la justice vous
voulez en faire quoi lui dire devant un
tribunal tu c'est pas bien ce que tu as
fait he bon allez 10 ans en prison et
après on verra non non les mecs arrêtez
on arrête d'être gentil maintenant ça
suffit on arrête les conneries les mecs
il viennent pour nous apprendre moi mon
plus gros regret c'est d'avoir arrêté
l'école à 14 ans j'ai pas j'ai pas
profiter des profs les profs c'est ce
qu'il y a de plus beau donc laissez les
envie arrêtez on arrête 2 minutes
d'égorger des profs Samuel pati on a
rien fait même pas une école il y a
aucun responsable politique qui a eu le
courage de dire on va faire une école
Samuel Patti peu importe la ville on va
en faire une cun je m'en fous des
menaces alors faut pas dire on baisse
pas les yeux tu as baissé les yeux as
baissé les yeux d'AC je suis d'accord
mais que les politiques ne viennent pas
comme
j'ai
professur ils on pe alors qu' disent pas
on baisse pas les yeux disent on baiss
place
professs je parle des politiques je
parle pas professur professur on un
courage incroyable moi je suis prof il
arrive ça je vais même plus en cours
remercier d'être venu nous voir vraiment
et c'est important pour nous d'avoir ton
témoignage et on pense tous bien sûr
très fort comme tu l'as dit à à la fam
j'aimerais juste saluer deux professeurs
justement que j'ai eu donc un professeur
de mathématiques que j'ai au collège
monsieur Lourdel que j'ai vu témoigner
et qui a eu exactement la M la même
description que tous et monsieur verag
qui a directement été touché puisque
c'est le prof de PS qui qui a été
poignardé que j'ai eu également en cours
voilà merci cétait important d'avoir
Antoine ce soir on pense bien sûr à
toute la famille de Dominique Bernard
merci on se retrouve dans un instant
tout de
suite